yeah there were a few missed
opportunities for you today Magnus how
will you sum up the match as a whole
um you know what uh this is one of the
days that I I mean I woke up after a
long long sleep I had some breakfast
maybe some too much breakfast because
afterwards I was spent and I could not
recover for the whole game so I think
the match was of uh really really poor
quality
uh and I think you probably would agree
as well uh so normally uh especially the
second game I get an opportunity which I
should never in a million years Miss and
also in this first game I was was much
better and it didn't feel like he was
playing at nearly his best so I think
the chances are pretty high that I'll be
facing him again and then I think we'll
just I hope that we both can a bit
better because this was I think I much
that it was not representative of any
hour of our levels